is responsible
of looking for the security of the
jewish community
we bought the jews from iraq syria from
yemen
ethiopia everybody puts them out there
as the top three
spy agencies what do you think separates
the culture of mossad
versus the mi6 or versus the cio or any
other agency out there
at all times we have to try and
identify signs and indications
of peace with with our present enemies
who
trained the mossad originally we were
trained
mainly by trial and elk would you put
iran at the top
threat in the middle east or who would
you put ahead of iran many represents
the most extreme group
that exists in islam they don't
accept us being a country dog
and obviously you're seeing what's going
on with america and we saw what happened
at the capitol
america has lost its crying statue
around the world and after the events of
the last two three days i don't see how
american can convince its other
allies around the world that the
best form of regime is democracy
my guest today is shabtai shavit who is
the former
head of the mossad and if you uh uh know
what the masada is known for we're gonna
get right into it they're known as a
top three uh uh uh strongest spy
agencies in the world with cia being at
the top then you've got the mi6 then you
have the masada and they have a rich
history
with a lot of respect he started in 1964
when he joined the mossad
and he became the director general of
the maasai which is the head of assad
from 1989
to 1996 with a resume and a ton of
stories
but he's kept it very low profile and
it's been 25 years since he retired so
he can talk with us today
having said that shabtai thank you so
much for being a guest on valuetainment
my pleasure so uh i understand you're in
israel right now how are things in
israel today
well uh you know they say that
the world is a global village so uh in
the sense of corona or the coveted
19 all over the world we uh we are at
the same
situation uh most of the time we see the
term
we are waiting for the vaccine to
get it and we are looking forward to
uh positive and good news some sometimes
in
during 19 20 21. very cool so
you may be in israel but we're living
with the same kind of uh challenges
everywhere same as israel so you know
obviously your resume you've dealt with
a lot of different things you were
involved
during the collapse of the soviet union
your the peace agreements with jordan
whether it's the assassination of former
prime minister
uh yuck or iranian revolution you've
been around with a lot of different
things but before we get into that
i'd like to know the story about how you
got into the mossad i know you were in
the navy before
how did your transition from where you
were out to getting into the mossad how
did that take place uh it started when i
was a
very young boy in our backyard we
we had the olive trees
and next to the small
village where i where i was born and
raised
there were two arab villages and during
the season
our arab neighbors used to come over
and they pick up the
olives from the trees at this
circumstance and at the age of
uh maybe five six i started to learn
arabic from our neighbors
and then in high school i was
[Music]
in a in a class
which was a pilot plan to establish a
in in the high school system in israel a
major studies of arabic
language culture and history of the
middle east
so i i admitted them that
and got chosen to uh to this uh class
and then when we uh really learned
arabic very uh intensively in the
history of the middle east and so on and
so forth
which took me
in the army after graduation graduating
from high school
i went to join the army and they took me
to uh
what we call in hebrews here
very one of the most famous swat units
in the
idf and one of the requirements then
at that time and i'm talking about
58 after com after completing my
um high school studies um
[Music]
arabic was the requirement one of the
requirements in order to
join this that unit i i
served my compulsory service of
three and a half years in the idf
at that unit and
then i went to the hebrew university
that time we had only one university in
israel
the hebrew university in jerusalem and i
took as a major
adult subject as well so when i when i
graduated from the
university i uh i was uh
loaded with the requirements
that were needed in order to join the
mossad
that's pretty intense to know that you
have to join the military and in order
to join a certain unit in the military
you have to speak a certain language
or else you can be a part of a pretty
intense requirement
yeah but it was a it was an exception
those years
and it was the only one place in the ibf
that the
foreign language was uh was required of
you now
i read somewhere that you went to uh
harvard as well did you attend harvard
university or or no
yes i attended the i attended the
harvard university the kennedy school
i did a master's degree in public
administration and it was
at the year of uh 1985
86 it was the sort of sabbatical
that i got from from the mossad
waiting to uh become the number two
of the of the organization i had to wait
a year
a year uh uh in order to
uh in order to get this this job so uh
they uh sent me to a sabbatical
talbot which was very generous
of the israeli taxpayer
and gave me a lot of
a lot of knowledge and and the
experience and
it was fun but it wasn't an assignment
it wasn't like you were working
it was just you went to school
now let me ask you you have a sense of
humor it's very from the moment i talk
to you even off-camera you have a sense
of here which is beautiful
who were you in high school if you and i
were in school together 14 15 16 years
old
who was shaptain high school
i was a i was a rather
[Music]
mediocre student i
i did not belong to the uh brightest
and and best best
pupils but i got along quite well and i
i had a lot of friends and uh during
high school you know
if you are smart enough to uh you find
you find a way as how to get
your first or second girlfriend
and it was uh it was really interesting
yeah
so was it just for your first second or
was it like a third fourth fifth which
one i'm just curious which one you work
[Music]
listen you are you are talking to a very
mediocre person i don't think so
not not somebody of the extremes okay
all right i mean you you you went to be
the director of the mossad which is
pretty extreme and career-wise where you
made it so
so then you go into massage and you
start kind of uh getting into getting
different assignments the different kind
of work that you do
at what did you at what point say i want
to go
become the head of mossad or was that
process of going getting involved to the
end of it was that accidental
was it intentional saying i really
believe one day i can be the head of
assad
or it just kind of happened accidentally
when i when i
when i joined the the organization
i i intended to uh to look at it
as a lifetime job and from the beginning
i i knew that i'm going to uh put in it
everything and anything that i
that i brought with me to the
organization and as i remember myself
excellence was one of the of the virtues
that
i cherished since childhood so uh
i knew that i'm going to uh you know in
order to
in order to uh to be upgraded and
achieve
such a goal it takes a lot
energy dedication and so on so forth so
i knew from the beginning then that
i'm going to try and having said this i
want you to know that uh
not only the musa in other places as
well
uh luck is also a factor
yeah i i i love your fire you can feel
your fire and the ambition you had but
at the same time you respect the fact
that
there is a luck involved in meeting the
right people and the right opportunities
that come up as you're
working your way to the top what what uh
you know
we spoke earlier and i asked a question
from you i said you know there's nothing
on you i have to really
i had to really work hard to find stuff
on you i mean don't get me wrong there's
there's
articles there's a lot of stuff there's
wikipedias there's
speeches there's but i had to go in
different places and have my research
team work
to find things on you why you know the
art director of cia
has millions of followers on instagram
social media obviously i'm being
sarcastic but i'm trying to say they're
celebrities here why
is it that in your world it's so low-key
and the culture is no one really knows
who's the head uh
in charge of mossad what's the
difference in culture there
first of all it's uh it's
it was it's not uh it's not now
since the world has become completely
transparent uh
changes occurred also in the
also in the mossad and in respect to the
identity of uh
of the of the director but uh
traditionally
um if i have to uh to define the
difference between
between the director of the mussar and
the
and the director of the cia
the latter is being nominated as a
political
nominee in our system
the director of the mossad is being
chosen
based on his merits and his expertise
political inclinations and the
membership
in political bodies is it
does not do not exist in in the
consideration to uh
to the appointment and another thing is
that
the the nomination of the
of the director is uh
being decided by one person which is the
prime minister the director of the
mossad is
reporting only to the uh
directly and and only to the uh
to the prime minister um the prime
minister is the
direct superior
of the of the director so
the prime minister is the one who choose
him
and usually
the prime minister consult with the
minister of defense and and the
ministry of the foreign affairs
and but the decision is the nomination
is the prime minister and
the relationship between the uh between
the
directoriums and the enterprise
relationship which which
resemble any other
set of uh relationship between any uh
minister or
uh general director of uh an
organization in the in the government in
the sense that
uh weekly meetings uh um consultations
and
um between between myself as the
director
and the prime minister there was no
anyone else so
so you know when when you when you read
about mossad
and and everybody puts them out there as
the top three
spy agencies you know us's neighbors are
canada and mexico let's just say right
okay we got cuba over here but let's
just say usn uh
canada and mexico you look at uk's
neighbors they're kind of by themselves
and they got a few neighbors over here
your neighbors are syria iraq lebanon
saudi arabia there's always conflict
going on you're a small little nation
you're not big you're very powerful the
reputation that's been built is you know
is one of a kind you know some of them
even call you i don't know if you guys
you know you like this this reputation
professional assassins
with a few boundaries and strike fear
and opposing
enemies and you look at the culture
uh and what it's known for you know uh
uh bringing justice to those who have
harmed the jewish people number one
number two neutralize military threats
to the state of israel
number three retaliate against the
perpetrators of terror
number four help jewish refugees reach
the land
of israel i mean it's a very specific
you know culture that you guys have but
i want to hear it from you
what do you think separates the culture
of mossad
uh versus the mi6 or versus
the the cio or any other agency out
there
there are quite a few topics which
makes the the mossad unique as compared
with the
with our uh partners the
americans in the and the brits for one
the mossad
is responsible of looking
for the security of jews in
around the world jewish communities okay
one two the mossad was responsible
in order to bring jewish people from
the diaspora who
lived in countries where they were
persecuted by
the local authorities and i can
i can name you along a long history
since the inception of the state of
israel and even before
that the the mossad by executing all
kinds of
uh of strange operations and activities
we bought the jews from iraq
we brought jews from syria we bought the
jews from yemen
ethiopia morocco and we
also brought jews from
iran after the revolution since
since you are familiar with with iran
the way we did it in
very generally speaking we used to
move them from iran to pakistan
and from pakistan to europe
from europe to israel and
quite a few iranian jews came
[Music]
by this way so uh this is another
uh another distinction between uh
between the uh
the responsibilities of the mossad and
and the other
intelligence organization
another another
another topic is uh in addition to
uh provide the the state of people and
the government of israel with
with intelligence we
at all times we have to try
and identify
uh signs and indications
of uh peace with
with our present enemies this is why
mossad was involved very deeply with the
peace process with egypt which was the
first arab country that
has signed the european treaty with
israel and the same goes for
the peace with between israel and jordan
the mossad was instrumental and and
played a major role in these two
pieces and we and we are
as i mentioned we are expected
and it is one of our jobs to try and
and identify um indications
and political changes in the region
towards towards peace another
another mission of the mossad that today
does not exist anymore
was to chase
[Music]
german former nazi germans
who were participating took part in
in executing jews during the
holocaust so these are mainly the
differences between
us and the the other intelligence
security intelligence organizations
who trained you guys because when i when
i read about the savage
savak was trained by cia and the mi6
right who who trained the mossad
originally just let me
let me head to what you just said about
the
training of the salah that in addition
to the americans
and the brits sabacc was trained by the
israelis as well
now we we were trained mainly
by trial and error because
the mossad was officially formed
after the inception of the state but
before israel was born
there were we had the what was called
the agana and palma
and all kinds of uh military
quasi-military
organizations uh that uh performed that
they
were acting in the in israel and the
in the middle east along the trail of uh
of independence which which which was
very lengthy
um we we learned by ourselves from
experience nobody so nobody
so so the mossad didn't go to another
agency to be trained you just kind of
learned on your own no no no
but what what mechanisms did you use
what did you read what did you studied i
mean
obviously you know your motto is for by
stratagems
you uh uh you age war you know you guys
are
you guys don't play around when it comes
down to uh uh being strategic is it were
you guys
required to read the book the prince
were you required to read the art of war
were you reading
napoleon were you studying what what was
the mindset because strategically you
can't just be born with that kind of
talent
let's break down the the question to uh
um to smaller parts
as much as the idf is concerned
the idf was trained uh
by other armies part of the training was
by
uh um israeli and jewish
uh uh officers who were sailed in in
in the british
army or in the american army
and who came to israel made
immigrated to israel and became became
officers in the in the idf and they
brought
and implement implemented whatever they
whatever they had experienced before
so that's how the training
of the of the military started and then
we
the idea started to uh to establish
a relationship with the with the foreign
armies
mainly with friendly countries the
armies and and and the
israeli officers were sent
to uh colleges and academies and
and foreign armies the
this is not related to the
muslim the mossad and the
uh security service what we call the
shinbed
which is the internal security service
we have grown up as i mentioned before
by trial
and error only experience and the
experience
started the experience started before
the inception of the state
during the british monday the experience
started prior to the inception of the
state
so so let me ask you this the the
conflict between between us and the
arabs
started back in the uh towards the end
of the 19th century
and at that time in in the tiny israel
during the british mandate there were
two different
people there were jews and there were
arabs living together
and having a conflict and
we didn't have a neither the time
or the uh resources in order to uh in
order to bring uh foreign
foreign instructors and foreign
experienced people in order to help us
uh
build out our security and military
capabilities we did it alone
um and and mainly
through trial and error i mean that's
the
that's uh that's
very very so i guess it
produces it makes me think about a
couple questions number one when mossad
first got started
did the mossad in israel
go recruit folks who were jewish from
other countries who trained in their
secret intelligence and military and
recruit them back to israel
oh no if insider i mean how do you but
it's
the reason why i asked this question is
look for example
i'll give you an idea do you follow
sports are you a sports guy or no
do you follow any sport okay
so if you follow sports if i'm a
six-year-old kid today
i can steal michael jordan's video plays
by watching his
youtube videos you know what i mean if i
play baseball today i can watch
and go study barry bonza's swing or ken
griffey swing if i play soccer
i can go study what maradona did or what
you know zidane did or what ronaldinho
does
but if you're you know a new secret spy
agency
there is no youtube videos to who do you
study
what book did you study what manual did
you that's a pretty
challenging thing to do when your
neighbors are syria iraq lebanon and
saudi arabia listen today we today we
we are already beyond 70 years since the
independence of the state even by
studying alone
um you can you can reach a certain point
of expertise
and i i don't know why
to me it sounds very very typical you
know when you
when you mention that jews
from other places
this was not the this was not the system
because uh you know when you when you
are
in an intelligent service and you uh
you establish a relationship with uh
with friendly
intelligence services around the world
the
the main rule is uh that you don't spy
on your friends
so today
we do have relations with other services
we
do exchange intelligence with other
services we do
meet with we do we do organize the
research meetings and evaluation
meetings and
and we also um here and there
participate in activities that resemble
um the the the definition of
studying or upscaling our capabilities
and but today when we do it it's uh on a
uh on a reciprocity kind of
uh of uh uh uh form
what's that again was there a mastermind
behind mossad was there like one big
figure that you guys all looked up to
and were trained by
his beliefs or training system
and manual and you know etc etc was
there some mastermind behind mossad
historically what i can tell you is that
the the first grain of the muslin
were israeli soldiers
in the british army participating in
world war ii and towards the end of
world war ii
those people those israeli soldiers
were assigned to find and
and gather the remaining remaining jews
from the holocaust
take care of them in order to bring them
at the end of the
end of the day to israel so this
group of people were the first
the first grain of of of the of the
mossad
when they finished their job of
gathering the remaining jews in in
in europe bringing them to israel then
and it was in the year of uh
51 uh the mossad was
legally formed and established
uh by the then prime minister david
benguya
and the mission at that point of time
has changed from taking care of
the holocaust survivors to
an intelligence organization which
which gathering information on
israel's enemies adversaries and so on
got it so so you know uh
there's not a major mastermind that was
training everybody certain tactics it
was an evolution of trial and error
yeah well of course we can we can
pinpoint to
uh um david personalities
who were at the head of of of this
organization since since its beginnings
but i cannot
i cannot recall of
any any kind who was experienced or
genius to the
extent that he could uh form
the organization from a to z
at one point of time it makes
it makes me think because if that's the
case why aren't other countries a top
three secret intelligence
if they if they can learn by trial and
error how come they don't make it at the
levels that you guys made it it really
makes me think about that but
let me ask you a different question let
me ask you a different question so so
you've been you've been
a part of assad from 64 to 96
that's 32 some years but from 89 to 96
you were the head of mossad and
obviously been retired now for 25 years
has the enemy of israel changed from 64
till today and what has that evolution
look like or
have all the enemies pretty much been
the same two three four five candidates
well the uh the world is uh is
changing all the time
and the world does not does not stand
still for a moment
and the same goes for the middle east
and for the
structure of the conflict between israel
and its uh
neighbors um
first of all we we can pinpoint to
the first peace agreement between israel
and
and and egypt and it it
it was initiated
by the wall of 73
on what we call yom kippur wall the the
grains
of peace with egypt started with the
with the wall of 1973.
the peace with jordan was signed in 95
after uh five six seven decades of
enmity and and then the adversarial
relationships in egypt
listen we can we can put the line in on
on 47th 1947 and king 48
is the baseline of uh the
adversarial relationship between israel
and its
its neighbors so the main the main the
domain and number one
a adversary were the palestinians
who were who shared the same territory
with
us and the main cause for the conflict
was
who who owns this territory
and then our countries joined the
palestinians in the war of independence
egypt was the first one syria
jordan joined the uh
the uh palestinians and then we
we found ourselves in what we named the
war of independence
which by by the way metaphorically
i can tell you that the war of
independence
has not yet
finished even today we
to a certain to a certain extent we are
still in
in in the in our war of independence as
long as
as long as territory the territorial
question
is not solved and as long as there are
countries that don't uh uh
don't um acknowledge the uh
israel is is as a as a sovereign state
in
in the in the middle east
the the wall for all particular purposes
is not yet
it's not finished and then we uh
the era of of the cold war
um and and the
walls that we had we can we can say that
uh every decade
since the uh uh beginning of the state
uh um every decade we had at least
one big war and uh
in between we we had all kinds of
uh of um small
small military operations and skirmishes
and
and then from a certain point of time we
had to cope with the uh
phenomenon of uh terrorism
which for uh three four decades
was a sort of a local domestic
event which was a
a civil
kind of of uh of uh
phenomenon who who who fought for
independence uh uh and
and and uh and then
after the uh during the the
uh spring
revolutions terrorism
adopted adopted the uh
the religious side of it and
and and instead of being a civil kind of
uh
of uh uh um entity
it has become a religious uh
uh uh entity and and and religion
um turn the uh phenomenon
of the terrorist phenomenon from a local
event to become global event
um the last
uh development of course is uh
what happened during the uh the last
few weeks or so that
the emirates countries
and morocco
have upgraded their
relationship with with israel and they
it's a it's a very positive
uh development which
which may affect the the future of the
region
maybe even towards uh
uh ending the uh
the ancient conflict between us and the
and the palestinians so uh the
situation is volatile the teacher the
situation
is ending is changing all the time
and of course uh uh um
it's not a a
two-party kind of a game
all the arab all the arab world is to
certain extent
is involved in it and then we have um
regional uh powers like iran
and turkey and then we have the
global powers russians chinese and
america
who are also involved in in
in this playground
so uh i don't know if i if i
answered you your question but
i believe that at least sparkly is
succeeding no that was uh
uh uh crystal clear and it's interesting
you wrote you said iran turkey russia
china those are the four countries i
have written down here that i wanted to
ask you about
uh how much were you involved
on finding out you know even have an
insider
uh a scoop on what happened with the
iranian revolution there's a lot of
different stories when they talk about
the
uh overthrowing of mohammed
palabi and how right after the dinner
with carter he
leaves in 77 december 31st they
you know toast and he leaves and almost
riots to protesting the revolution
begins
and then 13 months later a little over
13 months later
he's in exile and he's out and iran gets
you know turned over to khomeini
and things changed a lot and there's a
lot of different speculation on what
what took place you know whether it was
the
you know the 25-year uh contract of oil
that was coming up you know the consort
consortium agreement of 1954 between
iran germany us uk and i think france
and they had the secret meeting saying
let's get him to uh
dethrone him you know there's some
tensions with
what was going on with other reasons for
carter and iran there's a lot of
different stories that you hear about
but that's something
something that's close to me because i
grew and i've had a lot of different
talks with people that were directly
involved in that but i'm curious to hear
from you because if you were involved 64
to 96 78 79 and
you guys trained a lot of the savage
that came to you for
training there's got to be some kind of
a story or uh uh you know
or even factual reasons that you have
on why iran fell because they were doing
fine it's not like they weren't doing
good they were expanding and all of a
sudden they had to fall
what do you think was the reason behind
it you know there is a
we have a saying that a man is close to
himself
in the in the sense that i can give you
my personal experience
um you you didn't mention
the fact that i spent two and a half
years in iran
in person me and my
young and beloved wife
since since the beginning of 1966
to the summer of 68
um a relative long time
before the revolution
in in ion but
i can tell you for instance that
and and we we we spend time mainly in
the south
abaddon um
and and and the gulf those places
and i cannot forget
that uh uh prior to
uh each and every
memorial day to the uh
sacrifice of uh
the uh shiites prophets
hassan and hussein
the the the the government
called the foreign
people who lived at that time in iran
and they asked the foreigners please
remain in your houses during those days
of
uh memorial and i remember
that when i faced this uh
um unique unique
phenomenon because i didn't
i was i was not exposed to uh
to this kind of events
before i asked
as i remember asking myself
the question hey
how how is it going to
end towards where this
this religious
factor will will develop
and jumping from 66
7 and 8 towards the uh
uh um 70s and the end of the 70s
we and i i'm i'm speaking now generally
in general terms
our evaluation was that iran
going towards a revolution of the change
of the
regime we share this we share this
information with
with our american partners
i can remind you that at that time the
american
ambassador was was helms the guy who
who later on became the director of the
cia as well as much as i can
recall it
the americans have not accepted
our evaluations
and why is it so because the uh
the americans and other foreigners well
were
exposed to the military capabilities
of iran their evaluation was that
the shah was pretty much
ready and capable to cope
with any attempt of
a revolution he was ready
ready i mean ready militarily
okay in the military
the one the one point which uh
which no one at that time at least
at least among the uh the intelligence
circle
was that uh
what's going to be the uh attitude of
uh president carlton and uh as i put
together
all the pieces um
the shah waited
for president carter to node with his
head
like this and the
cartel didn't didn't do it not only did
he do it he expressed his of
his objection to uh
any military uh uh
step uh supposedly taken
by uh by the shah you know why though
do you know why though i mean this these
are everything you said you know
aside from the part where you guys kind
of knew the revolution was coming up and
you know he had a strong military the
shah had a very strong military he had a
strong secret intelligence that was
working with him the enemies he had at
the time was today
which was the communist party i'm sure
you're familiar with the two-day party
that was
running around in iran folks who were
leaving russia and coming
down with the karl marx book communist
manifesto and
you had the hezbollah that were kind of
growing underground he had 3 000
political refugees that he was keeping
where it wasn't going to be too
much ruckus going on he had great
relationship with us
i think he had a decent relationship
with israel why
why not support the shah and help them
out
to make sure they don't have the
revolution that takes place why keep
looking away and say no wait a little
longer and tell kissinger yeah we'll
help you but not yet we'll help you but
not yet we got it we got it but not yet
is there any anything you know that we
don't know on
why that took place i cannot answer for
the americans
i um i can tell you that the nature of
the relationship between israel and
and iran at that time um
the relationship well clandestine
was secret there was no
diplomatic exchange
open diplomatic exchange exchange the
the israeli embassy uh building in
in in iran was a sort of
a a a of an unknown
place we don't we didn't have official
relationship with you know so we
even if we wanted we couldn't and the
show didn't accept
it that that we had we offered him
listen
we'll come to uh will come to help you
and uh
and and so and so forth we we we weren't
in a position to
uh to replace the uh
the the us which was the uh the number
one
uh uh um
ally who was a uh
partner with with iran and the show
what i what i what i did they
emphasized was that we
we shared our knowledge
and assessment which which were based
on on on um
israelis on the ground
at that time well the world a
huge number of israelis of all of all
trades and and businesses and activities
in iran meeting and and
and doing business with with locals
and and based on the feelings
and personal experience of of
the israelis we welded we reached they
waged the conclusion that there is
something which
is which is which is
building up which is growing up
and this it was not based on
intel on on intelligence
because being being
allies of of iran we have not collected
intelligence on iran those days
we used iran as a the
back a base to collect intelligence on
on our enemies iraq the gulf and
syria and so on so uh
what we did we shared what we
what we believed with the americans
we uh more than that we you you can't
expect
expectance to do them did did
was it more peaceful for you as
neighboring
countries obviously iran's not a direct
neighbor but it's in the middle east
was it more peaceful for israel
and less turmoil with the
shah being in charge running iran or
ayatollah khomeini now
if if it will for us to choose
we would we would choose we would choose
the sun
romani represents the most
extreme group that exists in
islam the shiites is the most extreme
gold in islam they don't accept
us being a being a country at all they
don't
acknowledge our existence in the middle
east every
twice a week they come out with with
declaring their overall intention to
obliterate
israel of of of the earth
so uh the the
choice for us
if we if we could then
save the shah and iran
we would have done it we would have done
it
gladly and willingly um
listen you are talking about you are
talking to a guy who
was a big shot but uh
responsible on an operation which was
maybe
10 percent of the equivalent of the
of
yeah it makes me it makes me think
if if the the
level of turmoil on how it increased
right after the shah left
why why would have some nations
want more turmoil in the middle east
what benefit is it is it more powerful
negotiation for oil is it more
power to even uh have you
need america more israel need america
more because now you got
another person that's creating more
havoc which is iran and iraq war and you
kind of got to be careful
why what is the real deeper motive
of wanting because if kissinger and
carter know if they don't help
shit's gonna hit the fan in the middle
east like it's not like they didn't know
about it
everyone knew khomeini comes in it's
gonna be
catastrophic in the middle east which
that's what it could cost half a million
people's lives etc etc
i don't know why there weren't more
people trying to prevent that from
happening
and uh why they kind of looked away i'm
always curious again for me it's
it's the rectum it's kind of like when
for you you
you'll probably read or watch anything
that has to do with
you know the munich with what happened
with the israeli olympians with what
happened with
the holocaust or what happened with and
i'm not making it comparable on the
level of severity i'm just saying like
events that happen that affect your life
or
what imad mugnet did you know the
one of the founders of hezbollah that
you guys went and eventually you took
him out
those things matter to you because they
affected your
livelihood your country where you raise
your family for me
it was what happened with uh deshawn
carter and uh
kissinger and a uh of these guys so okay
uh fair enough i don't think is there
any other comments you have on this or
no
yeah look uh i i tell you what i'll
what i'll do tomorrow tomorrow is
weekend we here
i'll go to kissinger's memories in order
to
look for the chapter on iran to to eat
now what was
it what's then yeah
he's still around and counter is still
around
it it really it really makes me think so
the last thing we talk about here before
we wrap up you said a few things you
said
you know you have the smaller you know
enemies where you know the wall of
independence a lot of them hasn't been
done yet it's still going on but then
you talked about the bigger
you know potential uh powerhouses
uh in the world and obviously you're
seeing what's going on with america with
trump now finally you know the
transitions taking place with biden
coming in with kamala harris
and we saw what happened at the capitol
i'm sure you saw that in um
uh uh in israel on the news but who
you did or you didn't yeah who can of
course and i saw the origin the cnn and
fox and the others
what'd you think about it what were your
thoughts on that well i'm uh
it made me it made me very sick
what i saw what what do you think in the
direction
and look being being israeli
and and i don't i don't hide
the fact from for a moment
that israel is existence and israeli
security to a very large extent
is dependent on the us
i try to judge the events of the
last few days through the prism of
what is the what is the interest of of
israel in in in this
development and i'm sorry to say that
uh the first point that hit me
was that
america in the last few days
has lost a its uh
its prime statue
around the world israel america since
the end of world war ii was the
the the lighthouse of
of democracy of democracy of liberal
democracy
of marketplace economy of freedom of
equality
to the rest of the world america since
the end of world war ii to this day was
the
gallantell and the and the leader of
of of the western world and
after the events of uh of uh
the last two three days
i i don't see how american
can convince
its other allies around the world
and not to mention the adversaries
that the uh a
best form of
of regime is
is is is democracy
pick any
or the guy in brazil or the guy in the
philippines
or the guy or the the rulers of the
of the of the middle east and
can you argue and convince them that the
that democracy is the is the preferable
and the best um um
uh um regime in order to
you know to uh to build the world to
bring more harmony to build equality
what are you suggesting what do you what
do you what are you suggesting
is there a suggestion in that statement
of yours
well my i i i by far more modest
than trying to uh trying to define the
the future of the world but i can tell
you few words about the
uh possible eventual
development in in in the middle east
regarding the situation in the in the
middle east and
the conflict between israel and and the
and the palestinians
i believe that the the
the development which took place
in recent weeks namely the upgrade
of relationship between israel and the
and some of the emirates and morocco
is is is good news is very is very
important uh it it it
first and foremost it transmitted a very
strong
signal to the palestinians that
listen guys we were supporting you
since 1945
deep today but the world today is not
what it used to be
all in in the past and you have to
reckon with
with the changes that are taking place
in the in the middle east
now israel is not anymore
our enemy our enemy is extreme
islam being represented mainly by
iran who's pursuing
a nuclear military capability
this is the real threat now so you
palestinians
it's it's high time for you
to change your policy and
and and but there is there is an
additional
condition to uh
to what i'm saying one is that
the president-elect or the president uh
president biden should um
adopt a strategy that
the us is not leaving the middle east
and not only because of uh israel and
the palestinians because of many other
reasons because of the
because of the security of the of the
world
because the the russians
are competing with them because the
chinese are competing with them
because america
need to go on leading the free world
and and and leading the free world it
means to
to have a foot also in the in the middle
east
you should now bring in saudi arabia
and and create a new
axis of
u.s leading saudi arabia
israel egypt and jordan with which we
have
a peace already and the emirates
vis-a-vis the threats of iran
and turkey
and within this framework the
palestinian
will will be in a position that
whether they like it or not they'll have
to change their attitude and
and and policy and to become
a partner to a solution for the conflict
with israel let me let me ask you this
question uh would you put iran at the
top
threat in the middle east or would you
put who would you put ahead of iran
would you put them at the top as the
biggest threat
as an israeli
iran is the top threat to the middle
east
fair so here's my so here's my follow-up
question for you there go back the last
four
12 years okay last 12 years post-bush
era
obama comes in obama biden carried the
150 billion
deal with iran they negotiate and then
boom then trump comes in trump comes and
says
no the deal is off the table i'm not
helping you out and then he put
sanctions on iran iran gets weaker
22 21 nations in the middle east cannot
do business with them banks stop
blending too
many of the businesses there how do you
feel about the policies that was led
with uh obama and biden and kerry with
iran
versus policies of what trump did with
iran forget the personalities take the
personalities out
take the obama biden carry personalities
out
take trump personality out i'm
specifically talking about policies
which one of those policies made the
middle east safer
my personal opinion is the
policies of uh obama and
uh and biden to give 150 billion to iran
made it safe in the middle east
to to build the coalition with the
europeans
and to sign a an agreement
with iran for
which which gives us gave us
between 10 and 15 years
without without a an iranian
nuclear war with in the middle east so
let me ask you a question
another part of my of my answer is a
question
when when trump decided
to get out of the of the
agreement um
did he really considered
to uh to go to war
on this issue what do you mean
i mean that iran is iran is continuing
to build its capability
two days ago three days ago twenty
percent they announced the
uh the rest of the world that they are
starting to uh
upgrade their uranium
[Music]
here's a question for you but here's a
question for you for you for you to be
thinking about
say the 150 is given to them okay
say the 150 is given to them to you're
kind of buying them to not work on
nuclear weapons
do you really actually trust behind
closed doors
iran and the mindset that they have
where you don't exist do you think
behind closed doors they're not going to
be building a nuclear bomb
you really believe that
now uh the the decision
those days when when when uh when obama
made
the decision to uh to enter into a
negotiation
was either all
either i am ready to use
force in order to
knock them down similar to what we done
back in in 19 1981
in iraq or
what's the alternative buying time
time is time is the very essence
element the question i'm asking is do
you actually
trust that iran's not building behind
closed doors
[Music]
iranian merchants uh so i i
i recognize you know they're good
negotiators
negotiations yeah so so if you don't
trust that
if you don't trust that
i think it's naive to think that here's
a nation that
says death upon america i lived there
ten years ten thousand men march and
flagellating their back
trail of blood on the ground saying
death upon america
and then they hate your nation and we
give them money even though just last
week they say
screw both nations i don't and then
they're creating allegiance with china
and in july they're negotiating a 400
billion dollar investment in iran from
china
and you're looking at alliances being
created turkey is close to russia i mean
you kind of saw what happened with
armenia and azerbaijan where
russia kind of came in and to try to
settle things down and
why why strengthen iran that concerns me
and listen this is a guy that was born
and raised in iran
you know i i don't know if iran's
even if you give him a trillion dollars
if you're on behind closed doors it's
not going to be building a nuclear bomb
listen you you you
you look me to a point where i have to
ask you a question
please what's your alternative
my alternative is when i ask you a
question if you had to choose between
romania and shah
you said of course we would have chosen
the shah because it was safer it was
more peaceful it was less issues
my alternative would be if the iranian
people
don't like the current regime well why
don't you let them do ins
uh today what they did in 1978-79 when
nine million people revolted and there
was a fall of an empire
and then there was a different kind of a
you know regime that came in because if
we go like this
and the way you're shutting down people
who are threatening to take your life
is by saying let me give you some money
like your kid says
if you don't give me money dad i will
never love you and i'm gonna marry the
guy you don't want me to marry
baby please don't marry that guy here's
a million dollars okay i'm not gonna
marry him i don't understand that tactic
i just don't understand that tactic so
for me you know
i would say leave them alone leave the
sanctions
let them finally realize look we need to
get our act together we can't be going
around talking about threatening iran
and israel
and then they can come down and say can
we negotiate and we renegotiate and that
pain could take
6 12 24 36 months not oh my gosh please
guys here's some money stop killing
people i don't know if that's the right
strategy
again i'm just a person that's doing an
interview here
i'm asking you the expert to see what
you think about this because i don't
think the current approach
of giving these guys money is an
effective approach
the the people who listen to me
listen listen to you as well
let them jut between us
that's fair enough last question for you
thoughts on uh thoughts on
soleimani being taken out and uh mohsen
factorization taken out the number one
nuclear scientist when that happened
what did you think about like where did
your
mind go when you saw rasam soleimani and
and
fakhrizzada being taken out
i i i tell you what
what what my my mind
the notion then that
when we did similar
or identical operations like this
in the past no one in the world knew
about
it whereas today
those who those who does it make sure
that it will hit the headlines
very interesting very interesting so
so in other words if you have done this
you wouldn't have taken credit for it i
would have
not only late i would plan it
in such a way that i'll have
that deniability even after the event
well then you're in a league of your own
you know you're you're you're something
else when you were
the head of mossad but look i got to
tell you i really enjoyed this time with
you
i appreciate you uh taking the time uh
what time is in israel right now while
we're doing this brother i'm curious
what time is it there
is uh half past six past six well it's
time for dinner your family is probably
waiting for you
but uh i've really really enjoyed the
last 80 90 minutes with you
i appreciate your insight uh i uh
wish you nothing but the very best but
i'll give you the final thoughts what
are your final thoughts here that you
want to say to the audience that's
listening to this
i would tell them that
the world we live in
can and should be a better place to live
in
and at the end of the day it depends on
each and every one of us
had every one of us did a
drop of good deed
for that purpose we would have enjoyed a
a better world but first we have to beat
the corona
yeah it looks like pfizer moderna came
out with the vaccine and they're
spreading it all over the world so
hopefully
it'll get out there very soon tell me
do you speak falsely i do
really yes so i i'll beat you farewell
by saying hold our face really mercy
thank you take care bye-bye take care